mehdi bou said and entrevue prison en
fait je suis moitié algérien moitié
québécois oui ça existe mais dis depuis
toujours reçu ton diplôme de l'école
nationale de l'humour en 2013 soit fait
ton chemin entrevue dans la série en
route vers mon premier gala que j'ai
perdu lamentablement au final oui
bonsoir chers aux étudiants soyez vous
je suis très content d'être ici je suis
votre professeur monsieur flamand je
suis très content d'être ici à lui bave
l'université de blainville à verdun très
drôle
oui c'est un personnage que j'aime
beaucoup professeur flamme à qui il
manque un bras et qui fait un peu
l'apologie de dollar stores style c'est
ce que tu as faim ben c'était mon style
et ça l'est encore mais oui mais je
pense que parce que j'étais un peu tanné
d'entendre
les mêmes numéros qu'on voit au québec
je peins des numéros sur ma blonde m'a
laissé un numéro sur
gym un flat en roulant terry s'est
décidée excellence d'anecdotes sait très
bien la mener parce que c'est des gens
très talentueux qui font ces numéros ces
numéros là mais je voudrais qu'il
manquait sur cette espèce de
l'intelligence dans les numéros qu'on
retrouvait par exemple plus en france
dans les années 80 90 puis je trouvais
qu'il manquait sa à la culture
québécoise
j'ai été assez arrogant pour pour
essayer pour l'essayer ce que tu vois je
vais martily enfin martin ici pour les
pdg dit très bien je regarde deux par
match mais j'en prends le deuxième
monsieur en veut
enfin retour à l'arrière tu es né en
1991 mais tu es tu arrivé au québec en
96 à l'âge de 5 ans je ne parle pas un
mot de france aucun le seul mot que je
connaissais en france et c'est le mot de
demain c'est le seul mot que je
connaissais mon père m'a appris le monde
demain j'ai passé par le cheminement
classique des des immigrants qui
arrivent au québec sq ont été envoyés à
une classe d'accueil
donc on est dans une classe où il ya des
sri lankais des mexicains les
pakistanais les grecs et on a pris entre
nous c'est avec un accent pérou vient
parce que comme la profiter ou vienne
fallait qu'on on a appris comme elle
parle avec moi jusqu'à 13 ans je pense
je roulais mer
ah ouais ouais j'ai testé pour le genou
à terre je ne sais pas comment tout vous
que j'aille à l'école j'avais un accent
latino jusqu'à 12 heures parce que ma
prof m'avait appris le français quand
algérien d'origine avec un accident un
accent latino mais qui vit au québec à
mourir dans le quartier juif 6 mai c'est
ça montréal zinc est génial c'est ce que
j'aime de cette ville le cds grec dans
la salle non dommages auraient pris tout
ce team et et comment ses parents ont
réagi lorsque tu leur annoncer que ma
maman je vais très mal et très mal très
mal sait déjà qu'ils ont abandonné leur
carrière pour immigrer au québec qui ont
tout abandonné leurs amis leur travail
leur stabilité pour faire en sorte que
leurs enfants ont un meilleur avenir
évidemment qu'ils espèrent que l'on
devienne médecin avocat
ils vont arrêter ils m'ont passé les
menottes devant tous mes amis je
marchais lacoste je voyais jugement déjà
que mara ils l'ont eue l'arabe
pour eux c'était glissant l'ordre n'ont
pas vraiment je veux devenir clown je
veux faire rire les gens
ça a été ça été difficile il voulait pas
en fait il penser que c'est une blague
au départ c'est pour ça que j'avais
cette pression là qu'il fallait que ça
marche parce que palexpo attendant que
c'est vrai c'est possible de réussir un
humour c'est pas juste une chose est ce
que ça arrive parfois que dans la rue
des québécois d'origine maghrébine
interpelle pour te demander et je veux
être comme toi oui merci oui mais oui ça
me fait ça me fait tellement plaisir de
voir des petits dés
des petits immigrants qui viennent me
voir puis j'aime ce que tu fais et je
veux être comédien je veux faire ça
comment tu as fait pour réussir le fait
qu'ils s'identifient à quelqu'un en
regardant la télé qu'il fasse il ya une
place pour nous à la télévision
québécoise dans un milieu culturel
ça me fait tellement plaisir et puis
j'ai encouragé le go allez-y faites le
on me dit que rachid badouri est une de
ces grandes influences segret pourquoi
mais rachète une grande influence parce
que justement quand j'étais jeune fille
que je vois à la télé je voyais
maghrébins qui réussit mois maghrébins à
la télévision qu'ils réussissent pense a
été une manière pour moi de s'allumer
quelque chose chez moi je crois oui
c'est possible au québec d'être issu
d'une autre
une autre origine ethnique et d'aller
toucher le coeur des québécois et ça a
été vraiment cheveux sains mais aussi
des exemples mais dit que soit à 26 ans
son premier spectacle solo en rodage
mais qui va présenter ici à la place des
arts en avril 2019 alors de quoi nous
parle en ce moment je travaille sur un
numéro sur le port d'armes aux états
unis ça parle ça parle de racisme ça
parle d' inégalités entre les hommes et
les femmes à prendre si des sujets que
sont paul von à entendre normalement mon
spectacle
pour moi c'est hallucinant solution et
je propose une solution au québec
comment on peut régler ces problèmes là
comment on peut ensemble travailler sur
un plan d'action pour régler ses
problèmes pour notre et spectateurs et
spectatrices mais dit on voudrait la
solution maintenant c'est quoi ah il
faut venir voir le show la solution elle
existe mais elle est juste au chauffe on
ne trouve pas à l'extérieur donc venez
voir les choses c'est la seule manière
mais mehdi merci avec l'exercice